c'est le département qui a organisé ici
un concert dans le cadre des heures
vagabonde avec bernard thomas leur
caisse de bernard thomas et dans la
l'issue de ce concert bernard thomas
nous a dit qu'il y avait un très grand
musicien qui était un saint que nous
avons rencontrés qui s'appelle christos
nutella cacos et qui a trouvé le lieu
tout à fait séduisant l'acoustique est
excellente partout dans cette pièce on
voit de partout
toujours aussi bien on entend on pense
qu'on entend mieux dans les premiers
rangs on entend très très bien au fond
donc c'est très agréable et les artistes
insiste beaucoup là-dessus festival
s'est montée s'est enrichie au lieu de
deux jours samedi dimanche on a fait
trois jours qu'on leur dise à neuville
dimanche les plus grands interprètes
français sont venus là
donc cette année le vent au niveau du
programme
michel tout le monde aime un peu
entendre des choses qu'on connaît déjà
mais lui aime bien glisser quelques
oeuvres méconnues pour surprendre comme
musicien nous avons aussi encore des
grands musiciens
donc il ya trois trois pianistes qui
vont se succéder
vendredi ce sera emmanuelle stroesser
samedi ce sera claire désert et dimanche
ce sera à nouveau pour nos au festival
mais que nous aimons beaucoup beaucoup
et que nous voulions faire venir depuis
longtemps qui s'appelle adam laloum
voilà qui sera là pour les deux concerts
du dimanche
alors à côté de ces pianistes il y à un
violoniste qui sera là tout le temps
c'est régis pasquier bon c'est aussi une
des bases du festival régis pasquier et
la violoncelliste sera anne gastinel qui
viendra vendredi et samedi qui pouvait
pas rester dimanche et dimanche ce sera
pidoux notre lampe idoki qui est aussi
un des piliers du festival qui viendra
au violoncelle et puis comme solistes
invités il y a bernard cazeau rangs le
contrebassiste parce que a et c est en
même temps à un excellent musicien et un
il a une présence en scène qui est
extraordinaire il peut être très
amusante
d'abord il a le physique un peu de
groucho marx et il a eu une elle qui
fait rire tout le monde en même temps
qu'ils jouent merveilleusement bien de
la contrebasse
cette année nous avons repris cette
formule de faire deux concerts le
dimanche
séparés par un bon goûter un petit
goûter gourmand qui sera normalement
s'il fait beau servi dans le jardin
ce qui caractérise le le festival sait
que c'est ce que nous disent les
spectateurs des endroits où on écoute de
la très bonne musique classique y en a
beaucoup mais il y a une atmosphère très
chaleureux du bien sûr à notre directeur
artistique qui y donc qui présente
toujours des oeuvres avec humour et qui
met de l'ambiance
voilà donc c'est quelque chose qui est
décontractée et de bonne humeur
[Musique]